santé aussi la traditionnelle fête de la
musique aujourd'hui 21 juin jour de
l'été un peu mouillé certes cette fête
initiée par jacques lang est aujourd'hui
imitée dans toute l'europe
ambiance cet après midi début de la fête
dans les rues de paris nicolas winckler
marie-christine courtès il paraît que la
musique adoucit les moeurs
apparemment elle soigne aussi les
problèmes gastriques mais aujourd'hui
c'est la fête de la musique à leur
alléluia ses premiers ni les critiques
ni le public nord ont la dent dure
des milliers de concerts ce soir partout
en france est temps que le peuple
français et musiciens c'est donc tout
sauf du pipeau qu'on recense pas moins
de vingt-cinq mille groupe de rock 4000
harmonie 8000 chorale s'en parlait de
tous vos clics de fanfare
bel organe n'est ce pas le chant choral
fait l'objet d'un engouement particulier
depuis quelques années auprès des
adultes et surtout des jeunes retraités
oui la retraite c'est le nouvel âge d'or
l'âge auquel on peut prendre tout à la
fois la clé des champs et celle de
somain ce soir des goûts et des couleurs
ce sont les united colors of la musique
ça d'un pensée sur 10 pratique d'une
manière ou d'une autre une activité
musicale une tendance à la hausse
les adolescents sont deux fois plus
nombreux à pratiquer la musique que les
générations nées avant les années 60
l'instrument le plus vendu c'est la
flûte 2 millions chaque année fut alors
viennent après dans le tiercé de tête la
guitare et le piano
suffisamment pour faire ce soir chanter
le pavé à moins que la météo nous sommes
hélas et le temps ce soir est un peu
partout tristounet espérons que les
concerts des clercs ou de protestation
ne vous empêcheront pas nous faire la
fête tonnerre de zeus
ça